solo weary wedded welcome to today's
webinar post-translational modification
enrichment and quantitation for
precision medicine and drug development
presented by dr. Connie Jimenez and dr.
Manuel Soros I'm Christie jewel of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is present by lab roots and
brought to you by cell signaling
technology for more information on our
sponsor please visit our sponsor tab on
the left side of your screen and click
on the logo to be directed to the
sponsor website before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top-right of the
presentation window or you can report
your problem by clicking on the ask a
question box this presentation is
educational and the software is
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I would now like to present today's
speakers
dr. Connie Jimenez professor of
translational unko proteomics department
of medical oncology and head of the
Armco proteomics laboratory and director
of the proteomics core Amsterdam
University Medical Center and dr. manuel
soros project leader in proteomics and
mass spectrometry at Roche in Basel
Switzerland for complete biographies on
our speakers please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen dr.
Jimenez and dr. Cyril you may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much the title of my
presentation is it's on the cancer
phosphate proteomics and with this
webinar I would like you to gain an
understanding of the use of
phosphotyrosine and global affinity
enrichment workflows or label-free mass
spectrometry based forceful proteomics
and we imply this in the oncology
setting and therefore I will also talk
about our single sample integrative data
analysis workflow inka which is a key
for kinase activity scoring in single
samples and I'll highlight the the way
forward how we envisioned it to be
implemented in the clinic
so with this background just to remind
us about what is cancer it's it's a
devastating disease and the big
challenge is that every that the genome
cancer genomes are massively aberrant
with multiple gains and losses over the
genome and basically every every tumor
even if it's all colorectal cancers each
cancer has the individual aberrations
and therefore it's very challenging due
to this high complexity and
heterogeneity to predict based on on
genome data what the impact will be on
the downstream cellular signaling a
circuit that govern a growth and
proliferation and Auto Genesis and
progression of cancers and it's a huge
challenge for the oncologist to - yeah
to determine what is the best treatment
for an individual patient
well we we know that a lot of the
oncogenic drivers are protein kinases
and therefore there's over 30 right now
over 30 FDA approved kinase inhibitors
for the treatment of patients with
cancer but SSS already said the drug
response prediction based on genome data
alone is not sufficient for example if a
patient may have the EGFR mutation but
still not that doesn't guarantee a
response to an EGFR inhibitor and since
of course the proteome and the phospho
proteome is much more proximal to
function and these provide the activated
drug targets most spectrometry based
phosphoproteins offers an important
complementary view of cancer of tumors
and and may be very important for for
electing the right right therapy for the
right patients
while this this idea of course is not
not new and I would like to highlight
here a great pioneering study a
large-scale study by the people from
cell signaling we studied in this 2007
paper published in cell phospho proteome
landscape in lung cancer non-small-cell
lung cancer
they studied 41 cell lines and and 150
tumors and and and they came up with
very simple but effective ranking
methods the basal spectral counting
phosphokinase aswer ranked and and what
they observed was that whenever there is
a genetic alteration that is an
important in oncogenic driver that that
then this this based on spectral counts
that this kinase is can be ranked is
ranking high in individual samples and
and this concept that they used to study
the clinical the patient's humors and
discovered that there was great hate
regenitive signaling and in this
pioneering study new knew very important
drug targets in all small cell lung
cancer and were found using a
phosphotyrosine based phosphoprotein mix
and this basically this landmark study
inspired me to to really focus on on
phosphoprotein mix and implementing that
in the lab as a way to to stratify a
patient's for targeted therapy with
kinase inhibitors since then we we have
been successfully using the workflow so
this is just we do everything label-free
and this can be done large scale like
like was done in this pioneering study
so we have now lots of projects in lots
of tumor types where we add answer
clinically relevant questions and
biomarker development using this
especially this phosphotyrosine forceful
proteomics workflow but we also use
global fossil
this is just the background so now a
little bit I would like to share a
little bit more on the on the sample
preparation that we do and here we and
and what is well yeah so the the
phosphotyrosine immunoprecipitation
workflow using we use the new cell
signaling py mm antibody that is
conjugated to agarose beads and and in
our hands the protocol works really well
at a 5 milligram protein input level and
can be downscaled even to the one
milligram protein input level which is
compatible with tumor needle biopsies
well when you when you work with cell
lines the general remarks is to make
sure the confluency is constant across
experiments because confluency of course
influences signaling and it's very
important to practice the workflow
before you do a real paramount with
different groups or examples and make
sure you organize you you work in a
really organized and fast manner since
phosphorylation can can change rapidly
and you don't want free analytical
variables influence your results and
also when we do everything label-free
because that's a Advent as advantageous
when you want to go Bart scale clinical
sample profiling studies with multiple
groups that we make sure we always have
an alternating a study design where if
we have for example two groups that we
alternate gates and controls who have to
minimize the influence
different factors and in this way we
know we can do label-free proteomics at
large bill
so here we go just two steps the steps
of the protocol so we start with a lie
set of cells or tumor samples we digest
proteins - peptides with the salt using
18 separate cartridges then we lie off
lies the sample and then it's ready to
do the first tyrosine
immunoprecipitation a step after that
there is another negative desalting step
and then we typically analyze the the
for tyrosine and reach the peptide
fraction in a two-hour nano LC ms/ms run
and here we see the the performance of
replicates samples so it depends on the
on the cell line how many peptides you
get so so some cell lines have a lot of
peptides so in between let's say 550
knowledge peptides we get and this is
here we see the data for our reference
cell line HDB 116 that we always take
along in every sample so we in every
experiment so we know this the line
really well and and we can do the
capture at very high high
reproducibility with highly correlated
as spectral counts and we have spent
quite some time to trying to improve on
this on this protocol and and our idea
was if we get rid of the non
phosphorylated peptides because there is
a background of non phosphorylated that
if we can get rid of them then maybe we
can even retrieve more positives in
peptides that we try to use detergents
to click to do some cleanup but but that
did not did not really improve it we
have very the performance was really
stable
relative to the default protocol we also
tried titanium oxides a pre enrichment
of the global fossil proteome but that
also did not improve so we did not get
higher yields the only difference that
we can see is the difference between
generations now overall the the default
protocol works works already optimal
that is our conclusion and when we have
we have the wizened electrometer -
executive hf apparently the instrument
is already fast enough
to analyze those peptides and further
enrichment doesn't help
and so here just for comparison so
typically we like to do both enriched
separately for the phosphorus for soup
tyrosine-based for proteomic and then on
an aliquot of the unbound fraction of
the phosphotyrosine item we do a global
four so peptide capture using titanium
dioxide so typically we do two for
proteomics runs to get the good insight
into the whole proteome of sample and
and here we also see the performance the
Thai ox base capture and in the where
you can see it can be done by profusely
so up till now we we have now close to
2000 for proteomics
mez runs with over 12 million identified
fossil peptides ms ms spectra over
140,000 unique fossil peptides that
mapped to total 4437 protein kinases so
just in our in our lab from the past
years we've observed 82% of Pocono and
peas and in total 11,000 phosphoproteins
so these are the numbers so now a few
words on on phosphor proteomics analysis
of clinical material in our cases these
are tumor tissues now a guideline is
that after tissue Elisha's the protein
yield one to ten of the of the website
we like to make sections fresh frozen
tissue cryo sections to ensure fast
license of the sample and here you can
see the numbers of how many lashes we
typically you just input about 20 slices
of ten micron thickness so then we get a
very quick lysis and we use tissue to
lightest buffer ratios around 1 to 22 1
to 40 and we always do some test lysis
because we always want to get this right
and it because this is very important
for protein you and a reproducibility so
you don't want to use too little buffer
and then get low recoveries and naughty
slimy samples
and so we always for each new issue type
we always - you see
we have the option optimal
their general remarks when doing a
forceful proteomics experiment
especially when you want to do this
large-scale we keep the samples frozen
until the last moments we saw tissue
lysate one by one to avoid samples
spitting a long time on ice and waiting
to be processed so we'd really try to
avoid that and we saw we liked them
sequentially and then we do quickly the
the sample prep and well if we have
tissue cryo sections we typically do not
even need a bottle but for issues that
the learn little bit of a photo device
is say any
and when we before we freeze the the
lice eggs we always make some Ellicott
so a big aliquot of course for forceful
proteomics and make a few small
Ellicott's or for fossil tyrosine
western blot analysis and also for a
global protein taming to assess sample
quality
so tumor needle biopsies are its own
yield enough protein for the faucet are
seen work flow and we need we typically
hole biopsy for this additional and
emits a chill we one two three proteins
here we see the performance we thought
of took it to the test
taking multiple needle biopsies from the
same tumor and when we do an
unsupervised analysis use also proteomic
data we see that needle biopsies taken
from the from the same tumor that they
cluster together as you can see in map
colors and what you can also see is that
every every colon tumor has its own
oscillation profile so you can imagine
that
patience if we were to select an
inhibitor ancient that they would get
different
they're selected matched on the
individual profiles
so so fossil proteome data are very
complex that these are our large data
sets and and to make this flexible
practical every so we have been thinking
what kind of data analysis can be done
because in the end of the day if an
ecologist is to use this data we need to
boil it down to a simple report and and
this is what inspired us to to to make a
dedicated data analysis pipeline that
can enable fossil proteome guided kinase
inhibitor selection based on the profile
of a single sample or senior patient
and what we came up with a method that
makes use of all the all the data
resources out there so so we use the the
photocard data itself a la liga file
paper to sell 2007 paper that we ranked
on fossil kinase data but we also make
use of the kinase substrate relations to
inform us about option upstream kinase
activity and we make use of the carnage
motive data from from networking
so so basically what we do is we take
the phosphate peptide data to do a
ranking on the kinase observations and
active activation loops and we use the
phosphor side data to link to upstream
kinase activity using for suicide plus
database and networking and then we
combine those kinda kinase observations
and the substrate observation by a
purifier this formula it's a it's a
product so that means that there has to
be observations on both sides kinase and
substrates before we they a kinase was
active in example and and we have three
different outputs just a simple bar
graph ranking of infrared fairness
activities and a substrate network
and this this workflow was recently
published in molecular system biology
and we build a website where people can
upload that data
this is just to show you that so we
basically we benchmark this workflow on
on the number of Kansas Airlines
with no-one oncogenic drivers with
mutations or amplification and what we
see is that using this Inca ranking
based on carnation substrate data the
oncogenic drivers they they really rank
high in individual cell lines
highlighted the drivers so in this way
it works
and and also over here we have four lung
cancer cell line where there is mutant
of but you can already see that there's
other kinase activities that are quite
high there's not this outlier Avior and
and over here we we can look at the one
example of the kind of Surfside network
of a CML cell line that has hyperactive
able due to are able fusion and we know
that if we target this kinase with drug
that the cell line dies and and here we
have an example of a resistance cell
line you can so here we have the mutant
all in this lung cancer cell line but
you can see that there's a lot of other
hyperactive kinases and we know that
this cell line is resistant to single
drug opening in inhibition and the
patient here that we need one more than
one drug
and the Inca analysis gives suggestions
other tiniest targeting
so that brings me to the last question
can we predict which kinase inhibitor to
select based on a baseline inca profile
and to answer this question we analyzed
[Music]
patience right keno graft tumor models
for colorectal cancer and and we analyze
tumors from a well-characterized cohort
from Italy we collaborated with little
sue Cellino and and a few of these
models based on genomic they didn't have
genderless genomic aberration and we
asked question can we use Inga Inca for
target flex genomically unexplained
resistance the EX models follow cancer
and here we see that - - inca profiles
of - xenograft tumors where we see a
relatively high tivity of insulin
receptor and some other kindnesses and
to test whether this provides
alternative targets with treatment we
tested this in organoids
and we first verified using the photo
tyrosine immunoprecipitation were
coupled to inca analogy that the
organoids
have preserved the signaling from the
original tumor and
and the way we select the optimal kinase
inhibitors is we look at the whole inca
profile and we we match it with other
resources where we know how kinase
inhibitors are often at their target and
of type these drugs are quite dirty and
we make use of that to do an optimal
matching of of kinase inhibitors with
their target space and we map it onto
the target space the Inca profile for
example the BMS
insulin receptor but also other kindness
is highlighted does it work the answer
is yes the high ranking Inka kinase
started by the drug gives growth
reduction of the organisers of viability
reduction and when we combine two
inhibitors we get even much liability
reduction and and targeting a low
ranking Inka kinase able with
very important to target to high ranking
in cockeyed
this brings me to the end we way forward
we see that phosphor proteomic will be
part of a multi omics precision medicine
pipeline where we will use most back
trauma tree to generate phosphor
proteome wide single SH as a single
readout to determine kinase
hyperactivity relevant for cancer and it
doesn't matter whether hybrid 50 was
mutation amplification gene fusion micro
environment activation also proteomics
provides a great downstream readout of
vocal genetic hyperactivity poster
tyrosine workflow is very important
because it provides a high-throughput
view clinically relevant kinase and and
the incubation patient report with
strength kinetics is very important
fiction
and with this I come to the end of my
part of the webinar and I like to thank
all the people binnacle collaborators
so hello everyone now it's my pleasure
to walk you through the second
presentation of this afternoon's webinar
and I would like to present you on a
project where we automated kgg peptide
affinity purification and we did this
with with the tension of applying to the
identification of III ligase substrates
and just a quick outline of the
presentation I'll start with a brief
introduction and I'll follow with the
description of this the way we automated
the kgg peptide affinity purification
then I'll show you an application we had
on defining the substrates of the III
like a CBL B and then I'll conclude
briefly mention the next steps we are
currently working on and also briefly
acknowledge the people who did the work
protein ubiquitination is actually a
multi-step process that involves D 1 e 2
and E 3 enzymes and just to mention in
humans there are two e ones a bit less
than 40 e 2's more than 600 III which
can basically ubiquitin eight thousands
of substrates and these substrates
usually get ubiquitinated on lysing
residues and they can be mono as well as
poly ubiquitinated and this is um this
is because ubiquitin itself content
contains seven internalizing these
different ubiquitination architectures
they lead to different signaling
outcomes and probably one of the most
famous one is proteasome Allegra Dacian
but it is also involved in protein
trafficking for a proteomic degradation
that's basically what you have in the
figure on the left hand side of the
slide now the ubiquitin proteasome
system or UPS is actually a very
interesting system for the
pharmaceutical industry because it can
be used to degrade disease-causing
proteins and this can be done for
instance with the use of a de grader so
a de greater is a by functional molecule
that includes
host a target protein and an e3 like as
ligands and these two parts are
separated by a linker so as you can see
on the second figure on the left hand
side so integrator would be this
multicolor molecule that you see and it
basically recruits the ubiquitin loaded
III complex in blue it recruits the the
target protein in green and basically
catalyzes the ubiquitination of the
target and forces this protein to be on
to be degraded and in this whole context
it is important for for us also to
explore substrates of these III of III
like aces and their uses potential
target engagement biomarkers
the study of ubiquity long on a global
scale is helped by the fact that cell
signaling offers innate and anti kgg you
be ubiquitin remnants antibody and this
is something you can use in the
following context
so usually ubiquitinated proteins if you
digest these proteins using trypsin so
treating is an enzyme that specifically
cleaves after lysing and arginines so
all ubiquitinated part of a proteins
will basically generate peptides that
contains an internalizing that is
modified by a dike lysine residue on the
amino side chain group and using the kgg
ubiquitin remnant antibody you can
basically enrich for these species and
this you can do in a whole cell extract
that has been digested with trypsin
after affinity purification and
evolution from the beads you can analyze
the samples by LC ms/ms and then use
software's to identify the peptide and
also do some further bioinformatics for
relative quantification steps on it and
here I just want wanted to measure
basically the first report in the
literature that is a landmark paper
using this technology that was published
in molecular cells back in 2011 by the
group of team at all
now this global analysis of ubiquity
loans and this is antibody tools they
also come with a certain number of
challenges and first of all
ubiquitination is a low abundance post
translational modification which
requires large amount of starting
material typical recommendations there
are to start with at least 10 milligram
of protein or peptide sample but you can
see reports where people even go up to
50 milligram this is of course limiting
for certain sample types for example
primary cells or when you have larger
experiments where you want to compare
different conditions and replicate I
also have to mention that the use of
these PDMS can kids they require a bit
of training for typically new users
until they they work in a nice and the
reproducible manner so having these
challenges in in mind and also due to
the fact that in the last 10 years or so
there were some improvements made or
proposed fora
for this type of approach and namely the
group of juda she showed that you can
use this workflow in a high sensitivity
manner by lowering the antibody amount
that you are using variety as well as
cross-linking the antibody to them to
the solid matrix colleagues from cell
signaling technologies led by max oaks
also reported that you can run basically
one of these PTM scan in an automated
way using an assignment Bravo from
Agilent and more recently the Chris Rose
and colleagues showed that you can
combine
such a kgg and richmond experiment with
the tandem or TMT mass tax technology
when you want to do multiplex
quantitative experiments
so with these different inputs in mind
we optimized an automated kgg website
enrichment workflow which is basically
summarizing on this slide so we use it
for cells or tissue and we can do that
in principle from 1 to as many samples
as we have I mean typically we're in the
ran range of 20 samples proteins are
extracted we realize the the cells we
digest the proteins with trypsin and we
solve them by solid-phase extraction
then we take some protein a cartridges
and that we where we immobilize kgg
antibody and here there's a mistake
actually on the slide it's not 31
milligram that we immobilize the 31
microgram after immobilization of the
antibody we cross-linked the antibody to
the protein a cartridge use using
dimethyl PM eliminates or cmp after this
is done we perform the affinity
enrichment step of the kgg peptide and
this works down to one milligram of of
input material after that we alludes our
kgg peptides using 0.5% PFA and in case
we have a multiplexed experiment we can
TMT label our luh combine the samples
together if we need deep coverage of the
samples we then offline fractionate our
samples using pH 10 reverse phase and we
measure our samples by lcms on an
orbiter up Lumos and for this we use a
typically synchronous precursor
selection method or SPS
to get accurate quantification the data
we process using the proteome discover
software and muscat as a as a search
engine
so one of the first month to assess was
basically the effect of cross-linking
the antibody to the to the protein a
cartridges with BMP and what this would
bring as a as a as an improvement so we
did an experiment where we took just T
cells that we pre treated with mg 132
which is a proteasome inhibitor and just
guarantees that the ubiquitinated
proteins they accumulate in the in the
cells and the kgg peptide signals are
high enough that we can detect something
and in this case we used 2 milligram
peptide input material this is just
further for the notice being one of the
only experiments where we used 2
milligram material most of the other
cases we we used only one milligram so
we basically run two of these samples
using a non cross-linked protein a
cartridge and a cross-linked one and
after lc/ms analysis we basically got a
five-fold increase in kgg web site group
identification and this came along with
an increase in in the total number of
peptide groups that could be identified
by 26 percent and this also comes along
with an increase in the number of of ms
ms the instrument perform
what is also important is by using
cross-linking we also increase the
selectivity for the kgg peptides and
this went from seven to up to 28% so
there's really a benefit in
cross-linking the antibody to the two
the cartridges
then we did the following experiment of
course automation should basically bring
you a more robust workflow with less
variability in the data so we wanted to
access that and for this we perform two
experiments side by side where we took
chalk itself and five replicates tell
population we were treated with DMSO at
the control and five others with mg 132
and these ten samples each were either
run on the azimuth Bravo with the
automated kgg affinity purification
workflow or using a manual beat based
approach and here I have to mention that
we use the protocol as described in the
paper from you dashi
after running I'm sorry
ten tlu8 swear TMT labelled with the ten
plagues kids fractionated and analyzed
separately by LCMS we then plotted the
Lockton abundances of the reporter ions
for both treatments and plotted the data
of the automated versus manual data side
by side and then you can see them here
color-coded by for range in blue and
what you can see is that we have a
reduced variability when we use the
automated workflow as you can see the
boxes and the whiskers are smaller and
we also get less outliers and this is
actually more pronounced for the mg 132
treated samples compared to the control
one
next we wanted to assess if we can
basically reuse these cartridges and I
think this is a cool experiment that we
we perform basically we preferred two
cartridges that we loaded with 31 micro
gram and not 31 milligram of the kgg
antibody cross-linked with TMP and we
used again jerk it sells one milligram
inputs in duplicate and enrich them with
these two cartridges and then we read
that for five times in total
using always fresh sample then the 10 Lu
eights we had we also TMT labels that
fractionated and analyzed by lc/ms and
here again we plug the Lockton
abundances of the reporter ions and
basically you can see that there's no
observable decrease in perform so these
cartridges can can be reused
maybe I should mention here that this is
true for a certain amount of time which
right so all these five IPs will perform
within two days
now I moved to an application of this
workflow for studying the ubiquitin
ligase CBL B or cuz it'll be linear in
form a proton Cochin P which is a ring
type III ligase and is a known negative
regulator of t-cell receptor signaling
it is also involved until t-cell
activation control peripheral tolerance
and exhaustion degrading cplp with the
decorator that i mentioned earlier is an
attractive approach in cancer
immunotherapy and of course what would
be wishful to have are basically a
substrate of CBL be that could be used
that could be used as target engagement
biomarkers during the whole drug
development and optimization process
for this we perform the following
experiment we took Turkestan itself that
we treated with an SI RNA against CBL B
and also used a scramble sequence as a
as a control si R le and we also added
support team L t-cell receptor
activation by treating these cells with
an anti cd3 antibody we perform the
whole workflow that I described before
and we also actually took a portion of
the of the samples to perform protein
quantification after this we managed to
quantify it more than 8,000 kg g peptide
groups and 7,500 proteins
looking at the cplp itself with this we
managed to knock it down by 40% in this
experiment
now looking at the kgg dataset we
highlighted two interesting tires in
protein kinases sub-17 and lck which has
several license that were identified as
being modified by ubiquitination and
also modulated by them by CBL b and this
was actually quite interesting because
these two tyrosine kinase are known
interactors of t-cell receptor
furthermore the two kgg sites okay 484
of sub 70 and k3 79 of ltk are located
in the kinase domain and are upstream of
regular regulatory tyrosine sites so
these are two proteins that are still in
further exploration in the oncology team
with this I would like to conclude so we
basically optimize the workflow where we
load 30 microgram of kgg antibody on
protein and a cartridges for followed by
EMP cross-linking and this allows us to
automatically and reach for kg t baptize
down to one milligram of of cryptic
digest using the assignment Bravo in
combination with DMT ten or eleven Plex
plus pH 10 we were space fractionation
it allows us to quantify up to 8,000 kg
g side now this automation comes with
the the fact that it's it is it should
be offered operator independent and also
a shows Renu sample to sample
variability and I thing is that you can
basically reuse these cartridges and
then we apply the the word flow
successfully to their identification of
substrate of the III like a CBL be just
as a next step I wanted to mention that
we try to use the exact same word flow
with different sound
what if specific antibodies and
currently we we try out to use the the
antibody against methylated origins we
also try out to use bio simulated and
modest antibodies in combination with
streptavidin cartridges to do the
enrichment and this works also pretty
nicely in our hands
so last I would like to thank a couple
of people from the from our department
in particular Yanis con abuse who's who
was a master student with us for nine
months and basically he's the one that
generated all the data I showed you
today also Anna sank to the oncology
colleagues for the collaboration on CBL
be the people from cell signaling
technologies must ensure for providing
some some advice on how to use the the
KEGG antibody and finally serum and lab
routes for the for the opportunity to
present during this webinar and with
this I hand over to Christy for the Q&A
session
thank you dr. Soros and dr. Jimenez for
your presentation yes it is time for our
live Q&A now if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for okay let's get started
dr. Jimenez let's start with this
question for you
can the phosphotyrosine IP protocol be
combined with tae ik's capture on the
same sample and if so which order do you
perform the capture
yes though the answer is yes it can be
done on exactly the same sample so
typically we start with the the lysate
with the phosphotyrosine capture and
then we reuse an aliquot of the unbound
fraction of that capture or for the
titanium dioxide base capture and we
also for protein expression we typically
one can also do protein expression
profiling on another ellicott of the
unbound fraction but typically we do
that on on a fresh tiny Ellicott's of
the initial sample
thank you dr. Jimenez dr. Sara let's
jump over to you for this question
did you try other PTM scan modus
antibodies such as the sausages tyrosine
with your protocol on the athame at
Bravo
so yesterday I was mentioning in the
conclusion slide we we try currently to
use them the antibody against methylated
arginine we just very recently got some
some data it seems to work we just maybe
have to optimize it for for this
particular type of of post Franklin post
translational modification the
phosphotyrosine itself we we never tried
on the on the assignment bravvo so far
maybe I can answer there right can i
yeah so I know that people at cell
signalling have also successfully used
the si ma Bravo platform to to do the
phosphotyrosine immunoprecipitation and
they use two milligrams of protein for
that and and actually we are gonna we
just we are approaching purchasing right
now the Bravo platform the same uh
platform in order to automate our
phosphotyrosine IPS and other captures
on that
thank you now doctors met as I believe
this one's for you
now with optimization of current global
Fausto and Richard methods like high
aux-in iMac and speed of new MS
instruments like QE h FX and Tim top pro
why would you need Faso tyrosine
enrichment since it requires high input
milligrams protein lysate complex and
lengthy workflow and is expensive
all right well let me start by saying
that the phosphotyrosine part of the
whole fossil proteome is only about 1%
though even so so I'm reaching for that
1% is always better than a global method
then a global method because also if one
would want to achieve with the global
method the same performance as with the
phosphotyrosine workflow which i think
is difficult then you would need to
really start out with a very high way
higher starting amount and do a lot of
fractionation to to sort of get close to
the depths that one can get from from
direct phosphotyrosine capture poeple to
single shorts amazing
now it's it's very challenging if not
impossible to reach the depth of the
forceful tyrosine-based forceful
proteome in a global experiment so
that's why we we just we perform two
different captures like a consecutive or
sequential captures two to two rounds to
get the best of both worlds
thank you okay we have another question
coming in do you have to do a buffer
exchange between phosphotyrosine and tae
ik's enrichment
we have a setback stop desalting step in
between
Sepik cleanup
now the answer is yes there is buffer
exchange
and cute and we've another question
coming in a little lengthy in a few
parts I am working with lysine
methylation which is also very low
abundance as a good clinician I guess
that after the immuno enrichment you get
very low amounts of peptides and I'm
scared of losing a lot of them doing HTH
fractionation is this not the case and
isn't the sample after the immuno
affinity already much less complex and
did you get many more identifications
with the extra fractionation staff
I can take that one actually the very
first trials we did were measured direct
measurement of the air weights after the
IP so we didn't try to combine with the
iph we both read fractionation yet I
don't really know if this brings
anything but it's true that the numbers
of methylated peptides you identify then
will endure in the range of hundreds
only
thank you don't you throw now documented
do you foresee that far fro proteomics
will be part of clinical diagnosis in
the hospital in the near future or do
you believe it will remain in research
only
well I do think it will have eventually
a place in the in the in the clinic but
but we need to we are not there yet so
currently everything we do is is in the
research context applying for proteomics
to human needle biopsies collected in
clinical trials and see what the
additive value is directly one one to
one in comparison to genomics and and of
course we need to have we need robust
workflows we need to automate I think
mass spec will be the preferred readout
and in this context I think data
independent acquisition mass
spectrometry is is of interest there so
this is also something that we we are
working on a forceful forceful
proteomics using di AMS and n it takes
of course close collaboration with with
clinicians and apologist and and that's
so it I cannot say when this will happen
but I hope that we have strong proof of
concept in the coming five years and
then maybe in ten years from now it will
be as normal who run a fossil proteome
profile along with the genome profile in
the context of advanced cancer
it looks like we have time for one more
question dr. Cyril will have you close
out with this question how efficient is
the KGB peptide affinity purification
with your protocol
um actually to assess efficiency we
tried to synthesize heavy labels kgg
peptide standards and spiked them in a
sample at the beginning of the workflow
and see how much we would recover after
the experiment one trial with it that
didn't look actually to be very
efficient we recovered something like
10% of the peptides I think that's about
what you can get with this workflow and
however we we need to repeat this this
experiment to get more confidence
numbers there
I would like to once again thank dr.
Connie Jimenez and dr. Manuel twirls for
his time today and her time today and
for their important research we would
also like to say in collaboration our
sponsor cells signalling technology for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now before we go I would like to thank
the audience for joining us and for
their interesting questions and as a
reminder questions we did not have time
for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand and lab which
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon have a great day